all right everybody uh you asked for him
here he is uh anatoly yaakovenko
uh anatoly did i get your name correct
did i butcher it too bad nailed it
perfect great so
uh anatoly is the ceo of a little crypto
project known as solana
s-o-l-a-n-a
and
it's caught fire people cannot stop
talking about it at my poker game uh
everybody is really excited about the
potential
and
as a proxy for that the price
of solana has gone up 90
x not 90 percent 90 times since january
first of 2020 from uh buck and change
maybe two dollars to
166 dollars today
putting them as the sixth or seventh
largest crypto project depending on the
day uh blowing past
doge and xrp uh and right behind uh the
ethereums and bitcoins and
cardona and tethers of the world tether
obviously a stable coin we'll see how
long that sticks around uh welcome to
the program
anatoly
um awesome to be here
so uh you've got a long history in the
technology business you worked at
dropbox for a bit working on their
distributed systems and you were an
engineer at qualcomm
and you had your own voip startup at the
turn of the millennium
when did you first find out about crypto
and then how did you come up with the
idea or solana and what is solana's
mission a couple of questions there take
them as you like yeah so
early days for me and crypto were when
btc was just starting out and
i thought it was kind of silly and it
was the only way i was looking at it is
well i could probably optimize the
mining code and see if i can mine these
things faster than anyone else
but
things started moving so quickly by the
time i thought well maybe i should do
gpus somebody was mining it with gpus
already by the time i thought maybe i
could roll on fpga
there was an asic already for
people were kicked running a kickstarter
for sale and my true experience with
crypto was at kickstarter i forget the
name of the company
but they basically
built the system but then
mined
btc with it and didn't release the
actual hardware to their users until
they exhausted their advantage
and to me that was like
the quintessential crypto experience
system don't trust anybody
um
but i was an ancient an engineer and i
looked at it strictly from kind of an
engineering perspective and didn't
really understand the monetary or social
implications of it
for a decade i would say
yeah so uh
i think at the core of solana's value
proposition is that the transaction fees
and the the
block times are going to be extremely
low right now i believe
that your cost per transaction is
my gosh i don't even it's like
a thousandth of a penny or something
crazy like that explain to people who
are neophytes what this means in plain
english that
the the the block times and the and the
transaction costs are so low especially
when compared to say making a
transaction with bitcoin or ethereum
yeah uh bitcoin can do like i think
seven transactions per second
theoretically
ethereum
i think based depends on the gas
capacity but it's somewhere between 11
and 20 maybe 30 at most
um
but
with solana you're not limited by block
space there isn't like a a limit that
the network sets it's purely the
bandwidth available to the network
and bandwidth is plentiful it's this
thing that you can get you know for 100
bucks at home you can get one gigabit of
it in a lot of places
yeah and at a data center when you sign
up and put your box there they give you
one gigabit for free
because they really only care about when
you go over that and you're trying to
get 10 gigs or 20 gigs
of bandwidth so a network with one
gigabit available to it globally
should be able to fit you know half a
million of these things per second if
the software doesn't suck
so since it takes four to ten years to
build one of these
generic multi-purpose database operating
system you know any kind of complex
system like this we're four years in i
think we're like a factor 10
off that theoretical
uh so um
for people who don't understand these
concepts maybe you could help us
uh with
solana being a proof-of-stake uh network
versus say bitcoin's proof-of-work
network what does this mean for folks so
there's like a how do you know when
you're talking to somebody in the
internet that it's not a bot right that
it's not just like a bunch of
troll farms from
the old country or whatever that
that are all presented
hey that's where i was born
they're pretending to be somebody else
so
in proof of work and bitcoin the way
that they do this is you have to prove
that you burned electricity somewhere
and that's how you prove that
you are voting with something and
because
electricity costs money it's assumed
that it's hard to get a lot of it
and that's where the security of the
network comes from in proof of stake you
don't you're kind of trying to fake this
by
creating a virtual token which is ends
up being the underlying token that you
use for fees and everything else
that is used to prove that
you're not faking these votes and you do
that with a signature
from your cryptographic key and uh long
story short you can think of it as it's
no different than verisign
this long you know certificate chaining
that you see in old school web that
proves that you're talking to google
well imagine if google instead of having
one vote
per certificate chain that had
a billion votes that they could spread
out in in different amounts to everybody
else that's part of their google
certificate chain and all of a sudden
you can say well did two-thirds of
google agree on this thing got it um and
that that's really where proof-of-stake
comes from it's it's just a way to
assign weights to
to a public key
so when uh the solana network uh was
released did people mine the coins or
were they just issued in the world
they were issued much like their sign
issues a bunch of stuff uh like a bunch
of certificates in that initial genesis
block you had a bunch of validators a
bunch of
early investors and you know
foundation and labs and stuff like that
and once the network got running
part of
building these totally open
permissionless networks is
socializing the cost of uh operations
so who pays for the bandwidth who pays
for the hardware
um and spreading out that cost is you
bake in some
crypto economics is what they call it
but literally it's spam resistance
we have this token that represents a
weight in the network we want to make
sure that
people don't just flood the network with
messages they don't create too many
validators that vote and that token its
capacity
represents
the limits of how far you can push the
system
and
also participating in that system gives
you that token with the hope that it's
worth something for somebody to spam
this and therefore this thing is valued
so how many nodes
how many computers i guess would be a
way to say it for folks out there how
many of those exist in the network and
then what does it cost to do that and
then what do they gain by being part of
the network so on the network right now
the solana
mainnet beta
there is uh if i can tell look correctly
i can look check right now it's about
like 1100 voting validators okay um
testnet is like 2200.
who are those uh validators what is
their motivation how does one become one
so a bunch of these are
volunteers so to speak they're people
that want to earn tokens so being a
validator means you're running a box
somewhere
and somebody assigns you stake or you
self-assign yourself some stake and
those are the tokens that represents the
weight of that verisign certificate
uh that you know hypothetical
certificate and when you vote you get
rewards and the more rewards you
accumulate the more the more tokens you
have
this week in startups is brought to you
by silicon valley bank what's next what
if are we ready now what
these are the questions that can keep
founders up at night and no one
understands this quite like silicon
valley bank for over 35 years silicon
valley bank has helped thousands of
high-growth companies by providing
scalable financial solutions along with
insights and expertise that many other
banks just can't from healthcare to
hardware software to infrastructure svb
works with companies across the
innovation landscape at all stages of
the journey anticipating their needs
even before they do and by providing
access to insights and in-depth reports
sbb can help you make more informed
decisions and assist in turning your
great idea into a great business which
could be why fifty percent of us-based
venture-backed tech and life science
companies bank with svb learn more at
svb.com twist silicon valley bank built
for what's next